devastating storm surge is a major
threat along the entire coast of Florida
it could reach up to 15 feet in
Southwest Florida
that would reach the roof of a one-story
home the roof of a one-story home
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Naples where
the worst of the storm is expected this
afternoon Jonathan good morning and
Charlie good morning we're in one of the
neighborhoods that will become one of
the first victims and I want you to take
a close look at this home what don't you
see shudders this is not an isolated
case everywhere I have been around here
hundreds of homes without shutters newer
and older the people that I've spoken
with said they simply didn't have enough
time to put them up before they
evacuated the people that wanted to have
them said that there weren't the people
around to do the construction work
ultimately though it's not the wind
that's going to be the killer here we
are expecting wind gusts up to 135 miles
per hour right now we're getting them
sustained at 28 miles per hour as we
walk further here we're only about 3 3
or 4 feet above sea level
it's the storm surge we've been talking
about it all morning and I just want you
to see what we have to face as we get
out here to Naples famous pier just a
block of water here we're expecting 510
possibly 15 feet of water to be plowing
here from the Gulf it will all go into
this community which is why so many
people were told to evacuate as soon as
possible incredibly descriptive
reporting and scary for those people
there Jonathan thank you so much for
that